feel the warmth of the light  and be healed  the pain is gone  thank you so much that's incredible  he has so many other gods  and his wounds have healed  oh  it's you again  you're here  father varoot this adventurer saved my  life oh  so that was you  i sense goodness in them  this adventurer also seeks the ark oh  is that so  then we have much to discuss  is this the tablet indeed  this tablet contains all we know the ark  passed down for generations  in theory anyway  as you can see part of it is missing  such a large portion  i wonder what happened to it  the tablet was already like this when it  arrived at the cathedral  i think it went missing during the  transport  our attempts to recover it have failed  no one really knows how the portion of  the stone tablet disappeared  [Music]